let's see what I've
got what are Foundation models and how
are they useful Foundation models is a
term we coined at Stanford to
characterize the class of huge new
artificial intelligence newal Network
models that have been released recently
and are so influential but the idea was
that the same idea of having models that
were just trained by seeing a ton of
data from the world could be applied not
only to language but also to VIs
genomic sequences robotics other signals
like radar and that by having large
large neural networks see an enormous
amount of data they can get to
understand a lot about the world and a
lot about human languages if it's human
language data these Foundation models
now give us computer models with much
more understanding which are being
widely deployed and Reinventing what we
can do with artificial
intelligence